hey good morning why are there six
people outside who say they're waiting
to meet with me so you know how you love
me because you haven't had a single
meeting with anyone since I became your
assistant that's because every time
someone calls and requests a meeting
with you I always schedule it for March
31st why because I didn't think March
31st existed
30 days has September April March and
November June and November
today is March 31st I know so then how
many meetings do I have today
93. oh uh also Mark again we don't have
those extra small condoms you ordered
I called the factory it's going to take
a special order not just because of the
size but because of the weird shape as
well something they've never dealt with
before we'll talk people have just
really embraced this and planted the
coolest stuff and Tom is our Master
horticulturist he knows all the
scientific names for everything right
Tom yeah like this what's this Tom
um those are of course Tomatoes or
Soulja Boy tell us whenever Leslie asked
me for the Latin names of any of our
plants I just gave her the names of
rappers and those over there uh those
are some Diddy's we have some bone
thugs-n-harmoniums right here growing
beautifully those ludicrouses are coming
in great April document this key to any
fact-finding mission is to get right
into the Battle Zone you know it's like
George Bush when he flew over New
Orleans or Richard Nixon when he went to
China to see what the Chinese were up to
no oh oh oh oh oh oh
Wesley are you okay
yeah
Leslie I appreciate what you're trying
to do but once you go in there you will
see things you cannot unsee I'm a
feminist okay I would never ever go to a
strip club I've gone on record that if I
had to have a stripper's name it would
be equality but I'm willing to sacrifice
all that I've worked for just to put a
smile on your perverted little face so
don't blow this
Greg pakitis
would you like some boiling hot coffee
your face
thank you
my name is Bert Macklin I'm with the FBI
he's a jerk he is being such a jerk it's
an awful thing to say to a human being
are you crying I'm not crying okay I'm
allergic to jerks oh God what if they
don't speak English April you know
Spanish right to attend Tierra sent to
trabajo porque to eres and Felicia
Personnel oh good excellent
my mom's Puerto Rican that's why I'm so
Lively and colorful
this is outrageous where are the armed
men who come in to take the protesters
away where are they this kind of
behavior is never tolerating you shout
like that they put you in jail
right away
no trial no no nothing journalists we
have a special jail for journalists
you're healing right to jail you're
playing music too loud right to jail
right away you're driving too fast jail
slow jail you're charging too high
prices for sweaters
glasses you write to jail you undercook
fish believe it or not in jail you
overcook chicken also jail undercover
you make an appointment with the dentist
and you don't show up Believe It or Not
jail right away we have the best
patience in the world
because of jail first up please welcome
April Ludgate
[Music]
I'm 20 years old
I like
people
places
and things and Pawnee is my favorite
place in the world
okay folks just a couple more
contestants and then the judges will
decide our next Miss Pawnee a winner of
six hundred dollars in gift certificates
to Big Archie's sporting goods and
Emerson fencing company
for fence
cover a whole fence but it will defray
the cost considerably oh my God
I quit
okay I guess she really is quitting no I
didn't win but at least I didn't make
any new friendships
[Laughter]
hello did you get my proposal for the uh
possible rezoning of lot 48. I uh have
been busy I know but I think it would be
a really great thing for the new ride I
don't doubt it but it's really a
question of resource allocation and I
completely understand that but you and I
both know that if we want to find the
money we can
I'm running late oh I'll walk with you
see the thing is when we allocate money
for parts
are you in a lot of pain I was shot in
the head with a shotgun well it's
actually not that serious I just need
you to stay calm okay yeah I'm just
gonna stay angry I find that relaxes me
you want to come home with me don't you
work at Lady Foot Locker
here's what I think we should do
everyone should go around and say one
thing that they love about Tom I'll
start I really wish I could have your
body what no like tied up naked in your
basement no no I mean you're in good
shape and you can eat whatever you want
well that was weird Jerry
hey Mark
um a little birdie told me that you have
won unpaid parking ticket that's funny
because a little birdie told me that
your adoptive mother was arrested for
marijuana possession
what you didn't know that huh
I didn't know I was adopted
I have to go talk to her and you got to
give me something I can use does she
have any weaknesses
no what do you mean no way everybody has
a weakness not machines I honestly
believe that she was programmed by
someone from the future to come back and
destroy all happiness
I see just I knew that you had two
Ex-Wives named Tammy so I was hoping
that there was one that you got along
with and no I hate them both
on my death bed my final wish is to have
my Ex-Wives rush to my side so I can use
my dying breath to tell them both to go
to hell one last time would I get
married again oh absolutely if you don't
believe in love what's the point of
living
okay
here's the situation your parents went
away on a week's vacation they left the
keys to the brand new Porsche
they mine well of course not I'll just
take it for a little Spin and maybe show
it off to a couple of friends I'll just
cruise around the neighborhood
I shouldn't yeah of course I should pay
attention here's the thick of the plot
pulled up to the corner at the end of my
block that's when I saw this beautiful
girly girl walking I picked up my car
phone a perpetrate like I was talking
sound roof is open the music was high in
that girl's hand was steadily moving up
my thigh she had opened up three buttons
on her shirt so far I guess that's why I
didn't notice that police car I can't
believe it I made a mistake the parents
are the same no matter time nor place so
to all you kids all across the land no
need to argue parents just don't
understand
thank you thank you
just a little something I know
so what's up uh someone is on fire in
Ramset Park they need you to get down
there right away oh my gosh